the countries of Kalos and Johto can
produce two goods shiny charms and
berries yep you gotta love these worlds
created in these economics questions
okay
the table below describes the production
possibilities of each country in a day
so here it tells us that Kalos if it
puts all of its energy behind charms it
could produce ten charms in a day but if
it but all of its energy behind berries
it could produce 20 berries in a day and
then Johto all of its energy behind
charms 25 all of its energy behind
berries 75 given these numbers are based
on both countries having the same labor
and capital inputs who has the absolute
advantage in charms so pause the video
and see if you can figure this out
alright so let's just remind ourselves
absolute advantage is just as who is
more efficient who given the same inputs
can produce more and they told us that
these countries they have the same labor
and capital inputs so this is really
just a question of who can produce more
charms in a day and you can see very
clearly that Johto can produce more
charms in a day and I so I would say
Johto because they produce let me write
a little bit neater they produce more
charms per day charms per day with same
inputs same inputs so they are more
efficient more efficient so they have
the absolute advantage now this is an
interesting thing because our intuition
might say well whoever has the absolute
advantage maybe they're the ones that
should be producing charms but this is
what's interesting when we study
comparative advantage that that is not
always the case and I suspect it this
question will lead us there all right
next next question they say calculate
the opportunity cost in Kalos of charms
so the opportunity cost in Kalos of
charms
so when Kalos decides to produce twenty
ten charms they're trading off twenty
varies
or another way of thinking about it it
costs them 20 berries to produce 10
charms so we could say it costs 20
berries for 10 charms which is equal to
2 berries to berries per charm in Kalos
so there you have it the opportunity
cost they trade off two berries per
charm and actually let me make a little
column here the opportunity cost so this
is 2 varies per charm and I have a
feeling and if you're taking an exam say
an AP exam it's not a bad idea to just
fill this thing out so what is the
opportunity cost of they haven't asked
us that yeah but I'm just gonna do it
really fast what is the opportunity cost
of of charms in Johto well they are
trading off to produce 25 charms they
they trade off 75 berries so this would
be 75/25 this would be 3 varies per
charm 75 berries for 25 charms is three
berries per charm and if you want to
know the opportunity cost of berries
well you could just take the reciprocal
of each of these so in Kalos the
opportunity cost is one-half charms
charms per vary and then in Johto it is
one-third charms per berry then if they
wanted to produce 25 berries if they
wanted to produce 75 berries they would
trade off 25 charms so it cost them 25
charms to produce 75 berries or 1/3 of a
charm per berry so I'm just doing a
little bit of extra but then it's going
to be useful since the next question
they actually are asking us who let me
scroll up a little bit they're saying
who has the comparative advantage in
berries explained so berries whoever has
the lower opportunity cost has the
comparative advantage so we see here
that Cotto has the lower opportunity
cost in berries 1/3 is lower than 1/2
it's a lower opportunity cost of
producing a berry
so Johto has one third charms per barry
opportunity cost opportunity cost which
is lower than k Llosa's k Llosa's 1/2
charms per berry opportunity cost so Joe
toe has comparative advantage so Joe toe
has comparative comparative advantage in
berries and I apologize a little bit for
my penmanship I'm trying to save time by
writing a little bit fast but hopefully
me saying it out loud at the same time
it's making it somewhat less legible all
right
so the next question if these countries
were to specialize in trade who would
who would produce which could explain
well whoever has the comparative
advantage each will produce that one
so Kalos has comparative advantage Kalos
has lower opportunity cost in in let's
see they have the lower opportunity cost
when you compare them to oh let me say
let me put it this way for charms let me
write it this way Kalos has a lower
opportunity cost for charms Kalos has
advantage in charms and then we already
said Johto has advantage in berries and
so
Kalos or Kalos I keep saying it weird
Kalos produces charms
Johto produces berries produces berries
and once again this goes back to
something we touched on at the beginning
of the video even though Johto has the
absolute advantage in fact they have the
absolute advantage in either Johto is
not even though they can produce charms
way more efficiently than Kalos jo tous
is actually in this if you buy all the
arguments of comparative advantages
Johto should actually produce the
berries while Kalos should produce the
charms because they have a lower
opportunity cost in terms of berries now
let's answer this last question right
over here what would be a trading price
that Johto and Kalos would agree on to
trade charms for now you might be saying
well what's a price I'm used to saying
saying that in terms of just you know
maybe dollars or some type of currency
how do I answer a price right over here
well the key is is that we can give a
price in terms of opportunity costs so
they want a a price of charms so it
really could be in terms of berries so
let's see what let's look at each of
their cost of charms so Cael OSes
opportunity cost of a charm is two
berries per charm Joe toes is three
berries perch on
so let me write rewrite that over here
so Kalos Kalos opportunity cost of
charms is two varies per charm and then
Johto opportunity cost of charms is
three berries per charm and here we're
going to appreciate why comparative
advantage works we said that Kalos would
be the one that would focus on the
charms and so notice if they can if they
can sell the charms to Johto for
something that is higher than their
opportunity cost and lower than JoJo's
opportunity costs then they both benefit
and so a good price let's say you could
go half way between the two but it
really could be anything in
between the two let's say 2.5 berries
per charm they both benefit so they
would trade at this trade at 2.5 berries
for charm why does this make sense for
Johto we even though they have the
absolute advantage well if they produce
nothing but but what if they produce
nothing but charms it would cost them
three berries per or no matter what they
do it'll cost them three berries per
charm but now they figured out a way
through trade to get charms at two and a
half varies per charm and so this will
be a better deal for Johto and so one
thing to appreciate when we talk about
comparative advantage some people think
that it's about one country benefiting
more than the other but if you we assume
all the assumptions about comparative
advantage and well in our models then
it's actually about both countries that
are trading benefit they will both be
better off they will both have they'll
both get gains from trade and both will
be better off